explanations to the twin paradox are as
numerous
as the various channels on youtube which
purport to have them
but what most people don't know is that
in the eyes of the inventor of
relativity himself
almost all of these explanations are
insufficient
that is according to einstein there is
only one solution
that provides a completely consistent
answer to the mystery that has
fascinated so many adherents of
relativity
but what exactly is that solution and
how conclusive
is it really and does it actually
require us to leave the framework of
special relativity
where the paradox was formulated this is
dialect
with einstein gravity and a twin paradox
[Music]
in 1905 einstein introduced his special
theory of relativity
in a paper titled on the electrodynamics
of moving bodies
there he noted a peculiar consequence of
his new theory
namely that if a clock traveling at
constant velocity
is returned to a starting point it will
show less elapsed time
than a clock which has remained
stationary
now oddly enough even though relativity
is all about the equality of different
frames of reference
at the time einstein didn't seem to have
considered the reverse perspective
wherein the stationary clock could be
considered traveling
and therefore should also show less
elapsed time
rather this contradiction which would
eventually become christened
the twin paradox was not addressed by
einstein until 1911 when he was giving a
lecture in zurich
there when posed a question about the
clock example by a student
he was inspired to assert that although
a traveling clock runs slower
if it is in uniform motion if it
undergoes a change of direction
as the result of a jolt then the theory
of relativity
does not tell us what happens
by change in direction or jolt einstein
means acceleration
essentially he is saying that special
relativity cannot handle acceleration
so contradictions like the twin paradox
are outside its scope
this wasn't a spur of the moment defense
rather it was a claim
einstein truly believed and which he
repeated multiple times over the years
what's strange is that this claim is
most definitely wrong
special relativity has no issue handling
accelerated frames of reference its
postulates
merely have to be covariantly extended
in more complex forms
it's not likely this distinction eluded
someone as intelligent as einstein
more probably something else about
accelerated frames and special
relativity bothered him
but what was it exactly his take on the
twin paradox during his later career
gives us some insight
in a 1918 lecture einstein gave an
explanation to the twin paradox that
in a private letter to his friend
friedrich adler he indicated
he found preferable to all other
explanations
this solution however appeared to
require moving treatment of the problem
from special relativity to general
relativity
and likely because of that fact it never
gained wider acceptance as an
explanation
many physicists aren't aware of it and
most textbooks don't even address it
but without it einstein implied our
picture of reality
is incomplete so what is the explanation
according to einstein there are two
equally valid but distinct perspectives
to the paradox
the first perspective is that of the
earthbound twin
who sees her counterpart leave earth at
constant velocity
travel to the turnaround point briefly
experience a force
and then return to earth again at
constant velocity
because the space twin is in motion his
clocks run slow
and when he rejoins his twin on earth he
has aged less than her
this is the same as how the earth twins
perspective is usually described in the
paradox
but now let's consider the space twins
perspective
according to einstein the space twin can
claim that he is actually at rest during
his entire journey
indeed from his point of view it is the
earth and the rest of the universe that
are traveling away at constant velocity
turning around and traveling back again
and whose clocks are therefore running
slow
he can even say that it is his twin
along with the rest of the universe
that is accelerating at the turnaround
point not him
this is keenly distinct from the
viewpoint of the solution in special
relativity
where the acceleration of the space twin
is treated as absolute
and moreover where it is considered to
be the reason why
the twins's situation cannot be regarded
as symmetric
but in einstein's view we can still
preserve the cemetery
we can say that both twins have equal
right to claim
that they are at rest the entire journey
but how does this work how can two
completely different accounts of motion
remain consistent according to einstein
the answer is through gravity
[Music]
let's take a closer look during the
constant velocity portions of the trip
the space twin will see his earthbound
twins clocks
running slow just as in the usual
formulation of the paradox
however something unique occurs to his
perspective
at the turnaround point rather than
observe himself accelerate
the space twin will instead claim to see
a uniform
gravitational field arise throughout all
space
one that accelerates the earth his twin
and the rest of the fixed stars
towards him at the same time he feels a
force from his rockets which keeps him
from moving along
with the rest of the universe now
because clocks run faster farther out in
gravitational fields
distant objects will appear to age very
rapidly from his perspective
and thus by the time he finishes turning
around he will see that his earth twin
has aged through more elapsed time than
himself
this rapid aging will be more than
enough to compensate for the dilated
passage of time
he observed for his earthbound
counterpart during the constant velocity
portion
of her trip this is why when the twins
are reunited
they both will agree that the earth twin
is older
alright so that's the explanation it
definitely seems
a little out there so the question we
want to ask
is what's really being said here now
on youtube one of the few videos dealing
with this subject
is eugene kutoriansky's twin paradox in
general relativity
therefore adam will believe that the
gravitational field is causing time on
earth to flow much
if you read his comment section you can
see that there's almost more skepticism
surrounding this solution than
surrounding the conventional solution
many viewers see something absurd in the
idea
of suddenly observing a gravitational
field filling the entirety of the
universe
several commenters point out the fact
that since there exists
no source to produce such a
gravitational field it has to be
regarded as fictitious meaning the space
twin cannot truly claim that he is at
rest
einstein actually had an answer for this
latter objection
he claimed that the source of the
gravitational field could be attributed
to the motion of the fixed stars
that is he wrote just as an accelerated
charge
induces a changing electric field so
should an accelerated mass
induce a changing gravitational field
in this way an observer's worldview will
remain consistent with being at rest
even if they are accelerating
[Music]
we can begin to understand now why
einstein believed special relativity
couldn't handle acceleration
he thought that only by incorporating
gravity into the picture
could the relativity of all motion be
accounted for
and the twin paradox fully explained
otherwise
if you wish to resolve the paradox and
special relativity
you'd have to begin by asserting that
acceleration
is somehow a privileged absolute form of
motion
absolute motion was an idea that
einstein strongly disliked and which he
claimed
kinematically made no sense anyway
einstein's answer seems to wrap
everything up in a nice bow
so is there any reason to remain
skeptical of his solution
well it turns out yes einstein makes two
crucial flaws in his reasoning in his
1918 lecture
the first is with his electric charge
analogy while it's true an accelerated
charge will induce a changing electric
field
there's a distinct causal order to this
process that plays an important role
we can break down this order as follows
one
a force is applied to the charge two
as a consequence of one the charge
accelerates
three as a consequence of two a changing
electric field is induced
attempting to construct an analogous
order for the gravitational field
however
leads to a contradiction since from the
space twins perspective
we only have the following two
occurrences
one a uniform gravitational field arises
two earth and the fixed stars accelerate
einstein muddles the cause-and-effect
relationship of these two occurrences
in the first half of his lecture he
asserts that as seen from the space
twins perspective
two is a consequence of one that is that
the gravitational field is responsible
for accelerating the earth and the rest
of the stars
but then in the second half of his
lecture he claims that the acceleration
of the stars is what actually induces
the gravitational field to appear in the
first place
meaning that one would therefore have to
be a consequence of two
this circular relationship is obviously
somewhat problematic
the arising of the gravitational field
is even more problematic however
because from the space twins perspective
it appears in a non-local
instantaneous fashion throughout all of
space
this strongly suggests that the space
twin can't assert the reality of the
gravitational field
in fact the whole formulation seems
pretty ad-hoc
since obviously any intelligent human
observer would be
able to correlate the firing of his
rockets to the acceleration of
everything around him
and thereby deduce that the force fields
he sees are fictitious
like the ones observed from inside the
frame of an accelerating car
this leads to an important point about
gravity in general relativity
if an observer sees a gravitational
field that can be transformed away by a
change of coordinates
then the curvature of that corresponding
space-time region is flat
and there exists no real gravity
if the observer is unable to find a
transformation such that the
gravitational field can be made to
vanish
just as we observers on earth are unable
to do with our own gravitational field
then this indicates the presence of
curved space-time
or real gravity this means that the
gravitational field formulation of the
twin paradox
never actually leaves the domain of
special relativity
because the twins's space-time always
remains flat
[Music]
it's clear einstein conflates some of
these issues in his 1918 lecture
in hopes of preserving the symmetry of
the twins motion
but this brings us to the second flaw in
his reasoning the fact that he muddles
what it actually means
to assert the relativity of all motion
certainly an observer inside an
accelerating vehicle could choose to
assert that he is at rest
but then the laws of physics he would
have to develop to describe the behavior
of his system would be different
than the laws of physics an inertial
observer would use
this is exactly because of the force
fields he would have to invent in order
to explain
the motion of everything around him
this ability that is to extend the laws
of physics to non-uniform frames of
motion
by modifying their form is called the
principle
of general covariance now
as quoted from the beginning of the
video einstein believed in what's called
the general principle of relativity
or the idea that the laws of physics
should take the same form
regardless of one's frame of reference
for a while he mistakenly thought he had
achieved this principle through the
theory of general relativity
but it was eventually pointed out to him
by a physicist named eric kretschman
that general relativity only upholds the
principle
of general covariance not the general
principle of relativity
in fact one can construct a generally
covariant
coordinateless framework for newtonian
mechanics a fact which surprisingly
indicates that we're no closer to truly
relativizing motion than we wore three
centuries ago
this means that explanations such as
eugenes which imply that general
relativity
upholds the quality of all frames in
motion are in fact
strongly misleading acceleration in
general relativity
is still an absolute phenomenon and can
according to the theory
be objectively agreed upon by all
observers
ultimately this means that the twins do
not have equal right to claim that they
are at rest
the entire journey so where does that
leave einstein's twin paradox
explanation then
well essentially his explanation is just
an application of the equivalence
principle
which asserts the equivalence of
accelerated frames of reference and
homogeneous gravitational fields
the key word here is accelerated the
equivalence principle can't even be
applied in the first place
unless we can objectively agree that a
given frame is accelerating
alternatively you can say that being in
the presence of a gravitational field
indicates that your frame is
accelerating but either way
what you mean by acceleration in these
cases is something that will be
objectively agreed upon
by all inertial observers
[Music]
now if you ask what in einstein's
explanation is responsible for causing
the difference in the twins experiences
you'll find that the answer is still the
force the space twin feels when he fires
his rockets
which is the same answer you'd get from
the special relativity solution
in fact if you stack the two
explanations side by side
the primary difference between them is
that in einstein's explanation the rapid
aging of the earth twin
is attributed to the gravitational field
whereas
in special relativity that aging is
attributed to the rotation of the space
twins planes
simultaneity this brings us finally
to what is actually being said by this
explanation which is that the
equivalence principle
essentially implies the equality of
these two phenomena
[Music]
so ironically it's not gravity that
tells us something about the twin
paradox
but rather the twin paradox that tells
us something about gravity
[Music]
so our final verdict gravity does not
resolve the paradox
incorporating it into the picture gives
us some insight into the equivalence
principle and points us in the direction
of general relativity
but the paradox itself never leaves the
framework of special relativity
and so those questions that continue to
plague us namely
what it actually means to say that force
is the agent of asymmetry
and whether that's ultimately even
correct we will continue to explore
in future videos
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
[Music]
you